AND GIRLS IN AFGHANISTAN HAVE
LOST NEARLY EVERYTHING THEY ONCE
HAD.
>> IT'S A THREE-HOUR JOURNEY
FROM SHAQUILLEA'S HOME TO THE
CENTER OF KABUL.
BUT EACH MORNING, SHE AND OTHER
WOMEN MAKE THIS WALK, DRIVEN BY
HUNGER AND THE NEED TO FEED
THEIR CHILDREN.
THEIR DESTINATION IS THIS
BAKERY, ONE OF MANY ACROSS THE
CAPITAL WHERE CROWDS OF WOMEN
NOW SIT PATIENTLY EVERY DAY.
QUIETLY HOPING FOR HANDOUTS.
>> SO ALL THE WOMEN HAVE BEEN
PRESSING PIECES OF PAPER WITH
THEIR PHONE NUMBERS INTO OUR
HANDS.
THEY'RE DESPERATELY HOPING THAT
MAYBE WE CAN HELP THEM.
>> SHAQUILLEA TELLS US ON A GOOD
DAY, THEY MIGHT GET TWO OR THREE
PIECES OF BREAD.
AND EVERY MORSEL COUNTS.
WERE YOU DOING THIS A YEAR AGO
OR HAS THE SITUATION BECOME
WORSE IN THE LAST YEAR?
THERE'S NO WORK THIS YEAR, SHE
SAYS.
MY HUSBAND HAS A CART, BUT NOW
HE ONLY EARNS 30 TO 40 CENTS A
DAY.
ONE YEAR AFTER THE TALIBAN TOOK
POWER, AFGHANISTAN IS ISOLATED
AND INCREASINGLY IMPOVERISHED.
LARGELY CUT OFF FROM THE GLOBAL
BANKING SYSTEM, AND THE FOREIGN
AID THAT ONCE FUNDED ALMOST 80%
OF THIS COUNTRY'S BUDGET.
IT IS ALSO UNMISTAKABLY SAFER.
ONE THING THE TALIBAN HAS BEEN
ABLE TO IMPROVE IS SECURITY.
OUTSIDE KABUL'S AIRPORT, SHOPS
ARE OPEN, AND THE STREETS ARE
CALM.
>> COVER MY FACE?
OKAY.
>> A FAR CRY FROM THE CHAOTIC
SCENES WE WITNESSED LAST SUMMER.
>> HE TOLD ME TO COVER MY FACE.
BUT HE DOESN'T WANT TO COMMENT
ON THAT TRUNCHEON HE'S CARRYING.
>> TENS OF THOUSANDS RISKED LIFE
AND LIMB TO TRY TO FLEE THE
COUNTRY.
>> STAY BEHIND HIM.
>> MANY FEARED FOR THEIR LIVES.
OTHERS THAT THE TALIBAN WOULD
TAKE THE COUNTRY BACK TO THE
MIDDLE AGES.
FOR THESE GIRLS, THAT FEAR HAS
COME TRUE.
THEY WERE JUST A YEAR OUT FROM
GRADUATING.
AND THE TALIBAN ANNOUNCED A DE
FACTO BAN ON GIRLS' SECONDARY
EDUCATION AFTER SIXTH GRADE.
NOW, THEY HAVE IMPROVISED WAYS
TO DEFY THE BAN, SETTING UP
UNOFFICIAL SCHOOLS WHERE THEY
CONTINUE THEIR STUDIES.
NAHEED'S DREAMS OF A DIPLOMA MAY
HAVE VANISHED BUT HER DRIVE HAS
NOT.
>> I SAY TO MYSELF I'M SO
POWERFUL, I'M STRONG, AND THEY
CAN'T BRING MY DREAMS AND WHAT I
WANT TO DO.
>> DO YOU EVER FEEL SCARED?
>> YES.
IT'S A RISK FOR US THAT WE DON'T
COVER OUR FACE AND WE STUDY OUR
LESSONS.
>> YOU'RE VERY BRAVE.
>> YEAH, I KNOW.
>> GIRLS' EDUCATION IS ONE OF
THE MAIN REASONS NO COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD HAS YET RECOGNIZED THE
TALIBAN GOVERNMENT.
A POINT WE PUT TO FOREIGN
MINISTRY SPOKESMAN.
WHEN WILL THE TALIBAN ALLOW
TEENAGE GIRLS TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL?
>> FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
GOVERNMENT, THERE'S A RANGE OF
MIX OF ISSUES THAT HAS LED TO
THE TEMPORARY SUSPENSION OF
SECONDARY SCHOOLS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT AND
SIGNIFICANT PART OF THIS IS THAT
THE POLICY OF THE GOVERNMENT OF
AFGHANISTAN IS EDUCATION FOR ALL
CITIZENS OF AFGHANISTAN.
>> AND YET ALL CITIZENS OF
AFGHANISTAN ARE NOT CURRENTLY
ABLE TO GET AN EDUCATION.
WHAT IS THE HOLD-UP?
>> IT SEEMS THAT INTERNATIONAL
ACTORS ARE UNFORTUNATELY
WEAPONIZING THE ISSUE OF
EDUCATION INSTEAD OF COMING
FORWARD AND INTERACTING
POSITIVELY, THEY ARE TRYING TO
FIND MORAL JUSTIFICATIONS FOR
SOME OF THE INHUMANE POLICIES OF
SANCTIONS, WHICH IS LEADING TO
THE COLLECTIVE PUNISHMENT OF THE
ENTIRE PEOPLE OF AFGHANISTAN.
>> DO YOU WANT TO SEE GIRLS
GOING TO SCHOOL AGAIN?
>> THE POLICY OF THE GOVERNMENT
OF AFGHANISTAN IS VERY CLEAR.
AND THAT IS EDUCATION FOR ALL
CITIZENS OF AFGHANISTAN.
>> THE TALIBAN SAYS IT WANTS TO
SEE PEACEFUL AND POSITIVE
RELATIONS WITH ALL COUNTRIES,
INCLUDING THE U.S.
BUT THOSE PROSPECTS WERE
DRAMATICALLY DIMINISHED WHEN THE
HEAD OF AL QAEDA ZAWAHIRI WAS
KILLED BY A U.S. DRONE STRIKE IN
A VILLA IN DOWNTOWN KABUL JUST
OVER TWO WEEKS AGO.
>> WE HAVE MADE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT THE GOVERNMENT OF
AFGHANISTAN WAS UNAWARE OF THE
ARRIVAL OR PRESENCE OF
MR. ZAWAHIRI IN KABUL.
SO FAR, WE HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
ESTABLISH AS A FACT, AS A MATTER
OF FACT, THAT HE WAS INDEED
PRESENT IN KABUL.
>> ISN'T THAT ALMOST MORE
FRIGHTENING, THOUGH?
THE IDEA THAT YOU'RE CLAIMING
POTENTIALLY THE LEADER OF AL
QAEDA WAS HERE IN THE CENTER OF
THE CITY AND YOU DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW ABOUT IT?
>> WE CONTEND THAT NOTION THAT
HE WAS EVEN PRESENT HERE.
BUT EVEN IF HE WAS, THESE TYPES
OF INCIDENTS HAPPEN EVERYWHERE
IN THE WORLD.
>> BUT THEY REALLY DON'T.
I MEAN, HOW CAN THE U.S.
POSSIBLY TRUST THE TALIBAN
LEADERSHIP, THOUGH, TO STAY TRUE
TO ITS PROMISE THAT IT WILL NOT
ALLOW SANCTUARY TO BE GRANTED TO
TERRORIST GROUPS?
>> IF WE LOOK AT THE
DOHA AGREEMENT, THE ARTICLES
THAT DEFINE THE COMMITMENTS OF
THE GOVERNMENT OF AFGHANISTAN,
ALL OF THEM HAVE BEEN FULFILLED.
AND IF WE LOOK AT THE
COMMITMENTS THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA HAS MADE, SADLY, THEY
HAVE NOT FULFILLED A SINGLE
ARTICLE.
BUT WE'RE HOPEFUL AND WE
CONTINUE TO URGE THE UNITED
STATES TO ADHERE TO THAT
AGREEMENT.
>> IT'S A BRAZEN POSITION THAT
COMPLICATES EFFORTS TO UNFREEZE
FUNDING TO HELP THE AFGHAN
PEOPLE.
MILLIONS OF WHOM REMAIN HUNGRY
AND RELIANT ON THE KINDNESS OF
STRANGERS.
JAKE, CNN HAS SPOKEN TO THE U.S.
ENVOY TO AFGHANISTAN, TOM WEST,
WHO BASICALLY SAID THAT THERE
ARE NOW NO PROSPECTS IN THE
SHORT TERM FOR THE U.S. TO TRY
TO RECAPITALIZE AFGHANISTAN'S
CENTRAL BANK, AND HE SAID THAT
IS IN LARGE PART BECAUSE OF THE
ISSUE OF THE SHELTERING OF AYMAN
AL ZAWAHIRI, THE PROSPECTS ARE
GRIM FOR ANY TYPE OF
NORMALIZATION IN RELATIONS
BETWEEN THE U.S. AND TALIBAN,
JAKE.
>> FASCINATING.
CLARISSA, HOUSE REPUBLICANS ON
THE FOREIGN AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
ARE RELEASING A REPORT
SUGGESTING THAT ONLY A QUARTER
OF THOSE EVACUATED FROM
AFGHANISTAN WERE WOMEN AND
CHILDREN, AND THE STATE
DEPARTMENT JUST TOLD REPORTERS
THE NUMBER WAS CLOSER TO 40%.
YOU HAVE REPORTED THAT THERE ARE
UP TO 160,000 AFGHANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR
SPECIAL IMMIGRANT VISAS.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE
AFGHANS LEFT BEHIND?
>> WELL, THERE ARE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF THEM, ACCORDING TO
THE STATE DEPARTMENT,
POTENTIALLY 160,000.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SAYING THAT
THEY DON'T KNOW THAT THEY WOULD
EVEN BE ABLE TO PROCESS THOSE
WHILE PRESIDENT BIDEN IS STILL
IN OFFICE.
NOT A WEEK GOES BY THAT WE DON'T
GET CALLS AND MESSAGES FROM
PEOPLE WHO ARE STILL HERE,
DESPERATELY SAYING LISTEN, WE
WORK FOR THE U.S. MILITARY, WE
WORK FOR THE U.S. EMBASSY.
HOW CAN WE GET OUT?
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF COMPLEX
BUREAUCRACIES THAT HAVE MADE IT
DIFFICULT TO TRY TO PROCESS THE
VISAS, THE MAIN ONE IN ORDER TO
GET THE VISA, YOU NEED TO HAVE
AN IN-PERSON INTERVIEW.
THAT WOULD HAVE TAKEN PLACE IN
THE U.S. EMBASSY IN KABUL.
THAT EMBASSY IS NO LONGER OPEN.
SO THERE IS NO WAY NOW FOR
PEOPLE TO GO AND HAVE THOSE
INTERVIEWS AND NO MECHANISM IN
PLACE FOR THAT TO CHANGE.
ONE MAN CAME UP TO ME ON THE
STREET DURING THOSE TALIBAN
FESTIVITIES YOU TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER, JAKE, AND TAKING THAT
RISK, HE SAID